françaises français mes chers
compatriotes nous sommes en train de
vivre des jours difficiles nous
ressentons tous en ce moment la peur
l'angoissé pour nos parents pour nous
mêmes face à ce virus redoutable
invisible imprévisible la fatigue et la
lassitude pour certains le deuil et le
chagrin pour d'autres cette période est
encore plus difficile à vivre lorsqu'on
habite à plusieurs dans un appartement
exigu
lorsqu'on ne dispose pas à chez soi des
moyens de communication nécessaires pour
apprendre se distraire et changer encore
plus difficile à vivre
lorsque les tensions sont là que les
risques de violence dans la famille
scande le quotidien et nous mesurons
tous dans cette période la solitude et
la tristesse de nos aînés et pourtant
grâce à nos efforts chaque jour nous
avons progressé nos fonctionnaires et
personnels de santé médecins infirmiers
aides soignants ambulanciers secouriste
nos militaires nos pompiers nos
pharmaciens ont donné dans cette
première ligne toute leur énergie pour
sauver des vies est soigné ils ont tenu
les hôpitaux français ont réussi à
soigner tous ceux qui s'y présenter ces
journées ces semaines ont été et
resteront l'honneur de nos soignants en
ville comme à l'hôpital
dans la deuxième ligne
nos agriculteurs nos enseignants nos
chauffeurs routiers livreur électricien
manutentionnaire caissiers et caissières
nos éboueurs personnel de sécurité et de
nettoyage
nos fonctionnaires nos journalistes nos
travailleurs sociaux nos mères et nos
élus locaux et j'en oublie tellement
aidé par tant de français qui se sont
engagés tous ont permis à la vie de
continuer au fond
et chacun d'entre vous dans ce que j'ai
appelé cette troisième ligne
chacun d'entre vous par votre civisme en
respectant les règles de confinement
grâce aussi à la vigilance de nos
policiers de nos gendarmes
vous avez fait que l'épidémie commence à
marquer le pas les résultats sont là
plusieurs régions ont pu être épargnés
depuis quelques jours les entrées en
réanimation diminue l'espoir renaît et
je veux ce soir vous remercier très
chaleureusement pour ce dévouement et
vous dire toute ma reconnaissance
alors étions nous préparer à cette crise
à l'évidence pas assez mais nous avons
fait face en france comme partout
ailleurs
nous avons donc dû parer à l'urgence
prendre des décisions difficiles à
partir d'informations partielles souvent
changeante nous adapter sans cesse car
ce virus était inconnue et il porte
encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de mystère
le moment soyons honnêtes a révélé des
failles des insuffisances comme tous les
pays du monde
nous avons manqué de blues de gants de
gel hydroalcoolique
nous n'avons pas pu distribuer autant de
masques que nous l'aurions voulu pour
nos soignants pour les personnels
s'occupant de nos aînés pour les
infirmières les aides à domicile dès
l'instant où ces problèmes ont été
identifiés
nous nous sommes mobilisés gouvernement
collectivités locales industriels
associations pour produire et pour
acquérir le matériel nécessaire mais je
mesure pleinement que lorsque l'on est
au front il est difficile d'entendre
qu'une pénurie mondiale empêche les
livraisons les commandes sont désormais
passées surtout nos entreprises
françaises et nos travailleurs ont
répondu présent et une production comme
en temps de guerre s'est mise en place
nous avons réouvert des lignes pour
produire nous avons réquisitionné d'ici
trois semaines nous aurons imaginer le
multiplier par cinq la production de
masques pour nos soignants en france et
nous aurons produit des 1000 respirateur
supplémentaires de plus sur notre sol
c'est respirateur si précieux en
réanimation
grâce à ces efforts nous saurons faire
face et nous allons continuer à
distribuer davantage d'équipements mais
comme vous j'ai vu des ratés encore trop
de lenteur de procédures inutiles des
faiblesses aussi de notre logistique
nous en tirerons toutes les conséquences
en temps voulu quand il s'agira de nous
réorganiser ces dernières semaines
soyons aussi juste avec notre pays ont
été marquées par de vraies réussites le
doublement du nombre de lits en
réanimation ce qui n'avait jamais été
atteint
les coopération inédite entre l'hôpital
les cliniques privées et la médecine de
ville
le transfert de patients vers les
régions les moins touchées mais aussi
vers le luxembourg la suisse l'allemagne
et l'autriche que je remercie la mise en
place de l'enseignement à distance
l'organisation de chaîne de solidarité
dans nos communes
la réussite de tous ceux qui nous ont
nourris durant ces semaines sans rupture
avec engagement le rapatriement de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
ressortissants français et européens
depuis des pays du monde entier et le
soutien aux français de l'étranger
très souvent
ce qui semblait impossible depuis des
années nous avons su le faire en
quelques jours nous avons innové osé
agir au plus près du terrain
beaucoup de solutions ont été trouvées
nous devrons nous en souvenir car ce
sont autant de forces pour le futur mes
chers compatriotes si je tenais à
m'adresser à vous ce soir après avoir
largement consulté ces derniers jours
c'est pour vous dire en toute
transparence ce qui nous attend pour les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
l'espoir renaît je vous le disais oui
mais rien n'est acquis dans le grand est
comme en ile-de-france les services
hospitaliers sont saturés partout en
hexagone comme dans les outre-mer le
système est sous tension et l'épidémie
n'est pas encore maîtrisée nous devons
donc poursuivre nos efforts et continuer
d'appliquer les règles plus elles seront
respectées
plus nous sauverons de vie
c'est pour cela que le confinement le
plus strict doit encore se poursuivre
jusqu'au lundi 11 mai c'est durant cette
période le seul moyen d'agir
efficacement
c'est la condition pour ralentir encore
davantage la propagation du virus
réussir à retrouver des places
disponibles en réanimation et permettre
à nos soignants de reconstituer leurs
forces
le lundi 11 mai ne sera possible que si
nous continuons d'être civique
responsable de respecter les règles et
que si la propagation du virus a
effectivement continuer à ralentir
je mesure pleinement en vous le 10 ans
l'effort que je vous demande durant les
quatre semaines à venir les règles
prévues par le gouvernement devront
continuer d'être respecté
elles sont en train de montrer leur
efficacité et ne doivent être ni
renforcé ni allégé mais pleinement
appliquée je demande à tous nos élus
dont je sais l'importance dans cette
période
je demande à tous nos élus comme la
république le prévoit en cette matière
d'aidé à ce que ces règles soient les
mêmes partout sur notre sol des
couvre-feux ont été décidés là où
c'était utile mais il ne faut pas
rajouter des interdits dans la journée
pour notre vie quotidienne
il faut continuer lorsque nous sortons à
appliquer les gestes barrière nous tenir
à distance et nous laver les mains je
veux aussi vous rappeler que tous ceux
qui ont une maladie chronique ou
souffrent d'autres maladies doivent
pouvoir continuer à consulter leur
médecin
car il n'y a pas que le virus qui tue
l'extrême solitude le renoncement à
d'autres soins peuvent être aussi
dangereux je souhaite aussi que les
hôpitaux et les maisons de retraite
puisse permettre d'organiser pour les
plus proches avec les bonnes protections
la visite aux malades en fin de vie afin
de pouvoir leur dire adieu
durant cette phase de confinement
le pays continue à vivre
et heureusement certaines activités sont
interdites car incompatible avec les
règles sanitaires
pour tous les autres secteurs
économiques
quant la sécurité des travailleurs et
des entrepreneurs est bien garantie
ils doivent pouvoir produire et l'ont
largement fait depuis maintenant un mois
pour tous ceux qui doivent être aidés
durant cette période les mesures de
chômage partiel pour les salariés et de
financement pour les entreprises seront
prolongées et renforcées elles sont
inédites et protège d'ores et déjà plus
de 8 millions de nos salariés et nombre
de nos entreprises pour les artisans les
commerçants les professions libérales et
les entrepreneurs
le fonds de solidarité apporte une
première réponse mais je sais votre
angoisse je les entends du jeu l'élu les
charges qui continuent de tomber les
traite les loyers les emprunts c'est
pourquoi j'ai demandé au gouvernement
d'accroître fortement les aides de les
simplifier pour vous permettre de
surmonter cette période
je souhaite que les banques puissent
décalé toutes les échéances beaucoup
plus massivement qu'elles ne l'ont fait
et les assurances doivent être au
rendez-vous de cette mobilisation
économique j'y serai attentif il ya donc
un travail dans les prochains jours à
poursuivre pour vous consolidez
économiquement dans cette période
rapidement un plan spécifique sera mise
en oeuvre pour les secteurs qui comme le
tourisme l'hôtellerie la restauration la
culture et l'événementiel seront
durablement affecté les annulations de
charges et des aides spécifiques seront
mises en place pour les plus fragiles et
les plus démunis ces semaines sont aussi
très difficile je veux remercier les
maires les élus locaux les associations
qui se sont fortement mobilisés aux
côtés du gouvernement
mais j'ai demandé à celui-ci d'aller
plus loin là aussi est de verser sans
délai une aide exceptionnelle aux
familles les plus modestes avec des
enfants afin de leur permettre de faire
face à leurs besoins essentiels
les étudiants les plus précaires vivent
parfois loin de leur famille en
particulier lorsque celles ci viennent
d'outre-mer seront aussi aider dès
mercredi le conseil des ministres
décidera des moyens financiers nouveaux
et le gouvernement apportera toutes les
réponses nécessaires à chaque fois qu'il
le faudra
le 11 mai prochain
mes chers compatriotes sera donc le
début d'une nouvelle étape
elle sera progressive les règles
pourront être adaptées en fonction de
nos résultats car l'objectif premier
demeure la santé de tous les français à
partir du 11 mai nous rouvrirons
progressivement les crèches les écoles
les collèges et les lycées
c'est pour moi une priorité car la
situation actuelle creuse des inégalités
trop d'enfants notamment dans les
quartiers populaires dans nos campagnes
sont privés d'école sans avoir accès au
numérique et ne peuvent être aidés de la
même manière par les parents dans cette
période les inégalités de logements les
inégalités entre familles sont encore
plus marqués c'est pourquoi nos enfants
doivent pouvoir retrouver le chemin des
classes
le gouvernement dans la concertation
aura à aménager des règles particulières
organisée différemment le temps et
l'espace
bien protégé nos enseignants et nos
enfants avec le matériel nécessaire pour
les étudiants de l'enseignement
supérieur les cours ne reprendront pas
physiquement jusqu'à l'été le
gouvernement précisera pour chacun la
bonne organisation qui sera nécessaire
en particulier pour les examens et les
concours
le 11 mai il s'agira aussi de permettre
au plus grand nombre de retourner
travailler redémarrer notre industrie
nos commerces et nos services
le gouvernement préparera sans délai ces
réouvertures avec les partenaires
sociaux pour que des règles soient
établies afin de protéger les salariés
au travail
c'est la priorité
les lieux rassemblant du public
restaurants cafés des hôtels cinéma un
théâtre salle de spectacle et musées
resteront en revanche fermée à ce stade
les grands festivals et événements avec
un public nombreux ne pourront se tenir
au moins jusqu'à mi juillet prochain
la situation sera collectivement évaluer
à partir de mi mai chaque semaine pour
adapter les choses et vous donner de la
visibilité pour leur protection
nous demanderons aux personnes les plus
vulnérables aux personnes âgées en
situation de handicap sévère aux
personnes atteintes de maladies
chroniques de rester même après le 11
mai confiné tout au moins dans un
premier temps je sais que c'est une
contrainte forte
je mesure ce que je vous demande et nous
allons d'ici le 11 mai travailler à
rendre ce temple supportable pour vous
mais il faudra essayer de s'y tenir pour
vous protéger pour votre intérêt nous
aurons à partir du 11 mai une
organisation nouvelle pour réussir cette
étape
l'utilisation la plus large possible des
tests et la détection est une arme
privilégiée pour sortir au bon moment du
confinement
d'ici là et dans les prochaines semaines
nous allons continuer d'augmenter le
nombre de tests faits chaque jour ses
skis depuis quinze jours et fait durant
les semaines à venir j'ai demandé que
ces tests soient d'abord pratiqué sur
nos aînés nos soignants et les plus
fragiles et que nous puissions continuer
de mobiliser partout tous les moyens de
faire des tests c'est à dire tous les
laboratoires publics et tous les
laboratoires privés
le 11 mai nous serons en capacité de
tester toute personne présentant des
symptômes n'allons pas testé toutes les
françaises et tous les français
ça n'aurait aucun sens mais toute
personne ayant un symptôme doit pouvoir
être testé les personnes ayant le virus
pourront ainsi être mises en quarantaine
prises en charge et suivi par un médecin
pour accompagner cette phase
plusieurs innovations font l'objet de
travaux avec certains de nos partenaires
européens comme une application
numérique dédié qui sur la base du
volontariat et de l'anonymat permettra
de savoir si oui ou non
l'on s'est trouvé en contact avec une
personne contaminée
vous en avez sûrement entendu parler
le gouvernement aura et travailler il ne
faut négliger aucune piste aucune
innovation mais je souhaite qu'avant le
11 mai nous a semblé puisse en débattre
et que les autorités compétentes puisse
nous éclairer
car cette épidémie ne saurait affaiblir
notre démocratie ni mordre sur quelques
libertés
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
nos frontières avec les pays non
européens resteront fermés nous
déploierons ensuite tous les moyens
nécessaires à la protection de la
population
en complément des gestes barrières que
vous connaissez bien et qu'il vous
faudra continuer à appliquer l'état à
partir du 11 mai en lien avec les maires
devra permettre à chaque français de se
procurer un masque grand public pour les
professions les plus exposés et pour
certaines situations comme dans les
transports en commun son usage pourra
devenir systématique
ce sera possible grâce à nos
importations et grâce à la formidable
mobilisation d'entrepreneurs et de
salariés partout sur le territoire pour
produire massivement ce type de masque
le gouvernement présentera d'ici quinze
jours sur la base de ces principes le
plan de l'après 11 mai et les détails
d'organisation de notre vie quotidienne
des points de rendez vous réguliers se
tiendront pour que nous puissions
adapter les mesures prises et ensemble
décidé de manière régulière d'ajuster
les choses alors à quelle échéance dès
lors peut-on espérer entrevoir la fin
définitive de cette épreuve
quand pourrons-nous renouer avec la vie
d'avant je sais vos questionnements je
les partage
ils sont légitimes j'aimerais tellement
pouvoir tout vous dire et vous répondre
sur chacune de ces questions mais en
toute franchise en toute humilité
nous n'avons pas de réponse définitive à
cela aujourd'hui
dap et d'après les premières données qui
seront prochainement affinée par ce
qu'on appelle les tests sérologiques une
très faible minorité de français ont
contracté le côté de 19 ce qui veut dire
que nous sommes loin de ce que les
spécialistes appellent l'immunité
collective c'est à dire ce moment où le
virus
arrête de lui même sa circulation parce
que suffisamment d'entre nous l'avons vu
c'est pourquoi la première voie pour
sortir de l'épidémie et celle des
vaccins
tout ce que le monde compte de talent de
chercheurs y travaillent
la france est reconnue en la matière et
à d'excellentes ressources parce que
c'est sans doute la solution la plus
sûre même s'il faudra plusieurs mois au
moins pour la mettre en oeuvre notre
pays investira encore plus massivement
dans la recherche et je porterai dans
les prochains jours une initiative avec
nombre de nos partenaires en votre nom
pour accélérer les travaux en cours la
seconde voie ce sont les traitements
nous y travaillons depuis le premier
jour il ya eu je le sais beaucoup de
débats dans le pays toutes les options
sont explorées et notre pays est celui
qui a engagé le plus d'essais cliniques
en europe
j'ai tenu moi même à comprendre chacune
des options possibles à m'assurer que
tout était essayé dans les meilleurs
délais et avec rigueur
il ne s'agit pas de donner un traitement
si on n'est pas sûr mais de procéder à
tous les essais cliniques pour que
toutes les pistes soient poursuivis et
croyez le nos médecins nos chercheurs
travaillent d'arrache-pied aucune piste
n'est à négliger aucune piste ne sera
négligé je m'y engage
voilà ce soir je partage avec vous ce
que nous savons et ce que nous ne savons
pas nous finiront par l'emporter mais
nous aurons plusieurs mois à vivre avec
le virus avec humilité il nous faut
aujourd'hui décider et agir en tenant
compte des incertitudes avec lucidité
oui parce que regarder l'asie le virus
semblait avoir été vaincus et il revient
dans de nombreux pays qui à nouveau
décidé de refermer leurs économies il
nous faut donc procéder avec calme et
courage mais ce que je sais ce que je
sais à ce moment mes chers compatriotes
c'est que notre nation se tient debout
solidaire dans un but commun on disait
que nous étions un peuple
indisciplinés et voilà que nous
respectons des règles des disciplines
parmi les plus rigoureuses jamais imposé
à notre peuple en temps de paix
on disait que nous étions un peuple
épuisé routinier bien loin de l'élan des
fondations et voilà que tant d'entre
vous rivalisent de dévouement
d'engagement face à l'inattendu de cette
menace nous voilà tous solidaire
fraternelle une con citoyens d'un pays
qui fait face concitoyens d'un pays qui
débat qui discutent qui continuent de
vivre sa musique démocratique mais qui
reste unie et je veux ce soir partager
avec vous au coeur de l'épreuve
cette fierté cette certaine idée qui a
fait la france est bien là vivante et
créatrice et cela doit nous remplir
d'espoir c'est nous
durant les semaines à venir le
gouvernement le parlement
notre administration avec nos mères et
nos élus locaux auront à préparer la
suite
pour ce qui me concerne je tâcherai de
porter en europe
notre voie afin d'avoir plus d'unité de
solidarité
les premières décisions ont été dans le
bon sens et nous avons beaucoup poussé
pour cela qu'il s'agisse de la banque
centrale européenne de la commission
européenne ou des gouvernements mais
nous sommes à un moment de vérité qui
impose plus d'ambition plus d'audace un
moment de re fondation
nous devons aussi savoir aider nos
voisins d'afrique à lutter contre le
virus plus efficacement à les aider
aussi sur le plan économique en annulant
massivement leurs dettes
oui nous ne gagnerons jamais seul parce
qu'aujourd'hui à bergame madrid
bruxelles londres pékin new york
alger ou dakar nous pleurons les morts
d'un même virus alors si notre monde
sans doute se fragmentera il est de
notre responsabilité de bâtir dès
aujourd'hui des solidarités et des
coopérations nouvelle il nous reviendra
aussi dans les prochaines semaines de
préparer la presse il nous faudra
rebâtir notre économie plus forte afin
de produire et redonner plein espoir à
nos salariés nos entrepreneurs garder
notre indépendance financière
il nous faudra rebâtir une indépendance
agricole sanitaire industrielles et
technologiques françaises et plus
d'autonomie stratégique pour notre
europe
cela passera par un plan massif pour
notre santé notre recherche nos aînés
entre autres il nous faudra nous
rappeler aussi que notre pays
aujourd'hui tient tout entier sur des
femmes et des hommes que nos économies
reconnaissent
et rémunère si mal les distinctions
sociales ne peuvent être fondées que sur
l'utilité commune
ces mots des français les ont écrits il
ya plus de 200 ans
nous devons aujourd'hui reprendre le
flambeau et donné toute sa force à ce
principe
il nous faudra bâtir une stratégie où
nous retrouverons le temps long la
possibilité de planifier la sobriété
carbone la prévention la résilience qui
seuls peuvent permettre de faire face
aux crises à venir
ces quelques évidences s'imposent
aujourd'hui à nous mais ne suffiront pas
et je revis je reviendrai donc vers vous
pour parler de cet après le moment que
nous vivons est un ébranlement intime et
collectif sachons le vivre comme tel il
nous rappelle que nous sommes
vulnérables
nous n'avions sans doute oublié il ne
cherchons pas tout de suite a trouvé la
confirmation de ce en quoi nous avions
toujours cru non sachons dans ce moment
sortir des sentiers battus des
idéologies et nous réinventer moi le
premier
il ya dans cette crise une chance nous
ressouder et prouver notre humanité
bâtir un autre projet dans la concorde
un projet français une raison de vivre
ensemble profondes dans les prochaines
semaines avec toutes les composantes de
notre nation je tâcherai de dessiner ce
chemin qui rend cela possible
mes chers compatriotes nous aurons des
jours meilleurs et nous retrouverons les
jours heureux j'en ai la conviction
et les vertus qui aujourd'hui nous
permettent de tenir seront celles qui
nous aideront à bâtir l'avenir notre
solidarité notre confiance
notre volonté alors prenez soin de vous
prenons soin les uns des autres et nous
tiendrons
vive la république vive la france